in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to an
episode of the new genius brain podcast
yes so if you guys are watching this on
the video it's been a long time coming I
think genius brain has been now on for
about a year it's been about a year
no so it's been about a year since I
started this podcast because I started
it roughly when we moved into that
apartment in Glendale right so we would
apartment in Glendale that's like we
moved in years ago yeah so we we've
Meryl and I have moved in and we've been
living together for about a year now but
when we first moved to to in together we
moved to Glendale and that's when I
brought the podcast there but originally
before that I was doing it at the condo
that I was living in downstairs in that
breakfast yeah yeah you were doing it
over a year there so thanks to all the
patreon people you guys are paying the
rent for the new podcast room so I know
that it seems like you know I'm using
this money to ball out I'm not I
actually saved that that money to
actually open up this podcast so it's
been about that patreon now for about a
few months and with that with the
patreon help the patreon tzer's helps
they've actually helped open up the new
podcast room and so we got better sound
quality we got so much more
sophisticated in the last one the last
one was like fun
children bright colors now it's like
disrespect first of all I love that
podcast from home yeah didn't like it
why do you to yourself ETSU I'm saying
this is more sophistical you said it was
janky you had the look it was a fun
color like this you had the janky look
in your eyes yeah you use my yellow
chair I didn't we have to get rid of
that you know when we first moved in the
Glendale together so basically what
happened was obviously I proposed to her
and after that we were supposed to move
in together but I allowed Muriel to pick
out a place while I was gone and she
chose the best spot ever yes it was the
most convenient spot it was a good space
little did I know you had so much crap
with you no it's not that I had a lot of
crap which was the main issue but we
still have storage in this but this
place is bigger we still have storage
issues yeah cuz we had
Marie Kondo and that's exactly exactly
the point this has more storage remember
what I said when I came back and I said
this place is gonna be way too small and
you said no you were adamant that it was
more than enough it is like I said
little did I know I had didn't know you
had so much stuff with you because I
also had a lot of stuff you had a
one-bedroom apartment exactly I thought
as a dude usually they don't have that
much stuff to bring with them but then
you brought the whole kitchen first of
all that was already like dundie I was
like all right we definitely don't have
a no space when you brought the whole
kitchen we had to get rid of so much
stuff well you didn't cook at all no I
did cook what are you talking about you
cook the same thing though you cooked uh
whatever your veggie and me but when I
cook I cook I throw down so there's a
lot of different stuff that I needed
know exactly because I cook but you cook
so I didn't know what comes with that
cuz I don't see it cuz I didn't live
with you but then there's also a balance
because I don't have a lot of clothes so
see what I brought was 17 shirts for
basketball stairs thank God you had two
closets in your last place that you
filled up to the brim and so you had a
Marie Kondo a lot of your clothes yes we
did I mean I did I sure did so when I
think like the odd thing is is that oh
you know when most people just from our
friends yeah when they are together for
about what two or three years they
eventually move in together that's like
the typical thing to do after two or
three years because what's the whole
point of spending two separate rents
when you guys see each other all the
time right so we actually moved in after
four years so we prolonged it as long as
possible and those four years I got to
tell you we're the happiest were it was
so hard adjusting living with you
because we didn't realize how different
we were oh yeah like your level of
cleanliness versus my level of
cleanliness which we can agree from
asking our friends and your friends that
I am NOT that dirty your level of
cleanliness is pretty particular
particular but also you lied to me that
you were the clean person oh let me tell
you this one story at your place is that
one day in the morning we went to the
kitchen and
the sink was full of cups and bowls and
you told me I hate this I don't like
this I wish this could go away in the
dishwasher I understand why it's all
left here guess what I have to deal with
every morning at night now let me let me
okay
hey this wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast I hate bringing you
on let me let me recorrect your
correction rule tell everyone [ __ ] no
that's not the truth because let me
recorrect your correction my dear her
example of a sink being full is the
biggest exaggeration on earth can I tell
you one time I even have the text proof
to prove what you're saying she was like
irritated one day right she goes hey
next time before I go to work can you
make sure the house isn't a mess and she
says she sends a photo of the sink and
the counter right can I tell you what it
was the sink was filled with to the brim
with one cup and a fork inside the cup
and the counter had a pair of chopsticks
on it and that was a thing that was your
description of a full sink and a messy
house no that wasn't the only case and
that was probably you wear it that was
probably maybe like the tenth time I'm
like I gotta show him something than
nothing because you know what it's all
good is never completely fooled know
what you've been doing so much better
honey and I am so proud of you and I
really am grateful for you know what I
hate about you the most
then you try to act like an angel on
this podcast then after this after this
whole thing gets done when the demon
comes out this is a very poor depiction
of who you are and by the way on this
podcast at home she does not look like
you know why I dressed up like this
because you dressed up this is this is
him dressing up by the way everyone yo
can I say this though she has worn my
boxers for the past two months hey
they're very comfortable which is
fantastic yeah sometimes I don't have
boxers Emily where are
and their drapes I used the same boxer
for a whole week I don't know what
you're talking about
I fold your boxers every other day other
day every other day every day what did
the cow say every other day moving in
with her was such an interesting
experience I actually never yeah I've
had a couple of girlfriends before and
you know vibe dated around but I've
never ever committed to living with
somebody it was something that I was
deathly scared of I didn't I didn't
really want to also make sense with the
whole toilet situation well the toilet
situation thing but I'm just saying I'm
just adding sentence by the way people
are so dumb you know them don't they in
the beginning of the quarantine is gonna
be has so much time I was like I'm just
gonna respond to everybody but it was so
funny because 90% of them agreed with me
no cuz they're all women and so exactly
the funny thing was is that I'm not
gonna even really get into it but the
dumb thing was you know when you talked
about the peace bladder thing right
there like when you peace bladder just
clean it up why do you pee on the toilet
all the time it's like it's not all the
time I mentioned on the podcast that the
pee gets on the writ that I was peeing
on the top of the seat she's talking
about when it's left up and it splatters
so because I why do you why do you pee
all over the seats like no you dumb
[ __ ] it happens in the middle of the
night when the toilet seat is up you
gotta talk about it don't you because
people are dumb and I refuse to lose
that's my dick and I would tell
everybody he has done better job and I'm
really proud of you
and we figured out our compromise too
we'll just put both the seats down yeah
it's because when we talk about this on
the podcast right we're kind of
rehashing old thoughts they they think
that the argument is actually something
that we've been fighting about for like
six years or some [ __ ] but it's really
the the actual argument was like a
half-day conversation and then we just
tried after that it's so funny it's
weird because when people don't have an
experience with like a long-term
relationship they go oh god you you guys
you guys need some therapy I don't need
therapy for [ __ ] I love this [ __ ] right
here just my lady right here it's my
ride-or-die and she loves this [ __ ]
right here too
see it why can't you carry you say to me
at home safe for the podcast we don't
believe is real I feel like we do need
therapy today but yes you want couples
therapy you know time to time I think we
overcome them and like okay another
another tornado has passed by couple
couples therapy for I feel I meet any I
think a lot of people have the same
issue it's just sometimes we
misunderstand each other it's been
pretty good though for the past for
awhile actually it's been pretty good
cuz the tornado has passed by and we
survived you know and when something
like that big trauma comes around
together also to shout outs to her best
friend because she's right across the
street so she has somebody to talk to
talk to Becky and see what we're doing
and then she'll see it from an outside
perspective as she goes yeah maybe this
maybe yeah
and she has similar personality as you
so she doesn't always agree with God
because sometimes I feel like I'm crazy
I'm not crazy I you know if anybody asks
for any proof of any crazy stuff that he
said he doesn't do I have like what yes
lot died like mistake the sick I have
proof of what you think a full sink is
it's okay anyway I know I use multiple
cups right I have this very weird habit
now of using multiple cups which I
didn't have before because you know
you've had hold on a second girl let me
all those costed that sink in your old
apartment it's all it was not you know
why it wasn't my I can't but you know
why it wasn't mine because somebody else
did it so I made it a point not to do it
it turns out that when that person
doesn't do it now I'm allowed to doing
it so I started doing it I did not good
even asked Khalif and Ray it was never
would you like me to start on it so that
you could stop I'll use all the cups you
can use all the cups I don't mind but it
bothers you so I don't do it and that's
what you
call it good you don't say you try not
to do which I really do appreciate yeah
and you know actually that's not even
though we're part the career part is
that you when you have a leftover dish
or a bowl you put it in the sink and you
dump water in there with the remaining
food because you don't believe it
because if the food dries up it sticks
to the bowl so you get a moistened it
that's how you throw away the food first
not that's too much work you just let it
moisten and there's the most and so okay
and so I asked him because I was
thinking really hard and trying to be
the best person like maybe there's a
reason why he does this so I asked him
he's got so offended by it I didn't get
offended yes you're like why I'm like
because you got you got mad at me cause
like I really want to know if there's a
rational reason why you add water with
the leftover food and leave it in the
sink No
so this is what actually happened and
you got so mad cuz I was like please
tell me there's no no no no this is what
happened all right
correct she got upset because she wasn't
satisfied with my answer I told her I
don't know I just do it right and she
kept nagging me about yes you did
and I told her one of the things I told
her I don't like is that if you are
going to nag at me or pick at something
don't do it before we go to sleep going
to sleep angry and upset is something I
can't do no matter how upset she is this
bill could knock out and so what happens
is she'll say something she'll plant
some kind of evil thought in my head so
she'll do this thing nice she just goes
why do you do that right I go I don't
know it's just something that I do I say
usually when food sticks I try to soak
it in she goes what about wet food why
does for wet food I was like I don't
know like if it was ramen or something
and I left the bowl and I said I don't
know and then you kept being so
persistent about it because you weren't
satisfied with that answer she gave us
I think you know what happened cuz I
clearly remember I was like I just want
to know his rational reason I said I
don't know and so I asked to confirm
because like why do you do that and I
think because it was a nighttime he was
already agitated no no no no I was
thought that I was nagging
but really I was just very curious no my
dear
it was not like that at all I you kept
on being so persistent about it when you
should have dropped it after I gave you
the answer that's why I was and then I
told you what I'm asking because X Y & Z
so I give you a reason why I if it
there's no reason behind to it and why
it shouldn't why it's not beneficial to
use the water cuz it's just a waste that
you're wasting the water no and then and
then this is what happened after right
so she has a tornado so if something has
to happen her way she won't let it go so
for example that shake that hold on that
night what happened was so the garbage
can will slightly left the jar because
we had some cardboard boxes and stuff in
it right and then she goes I can't go to
sleep huh that same fish thing night was
the same night of the garbage can
incident because you couldn't go to
sleep because the garbage can was
slightly left the jar and then you
wouldn't let me go down stay and you
were like did you did you close the the
lid of the garbage yes that was the
reason why I slept downstairs because
you wouldn't stop nagging about it
before I go to sleep and I said the
world thing I don't like is to mention
yes and so what happened was she goes
well I can't go to sleep if I know that
garbage can is left ajar and I was like
yes and I said it's not a problem
there she goes well there might be and I
was like well there hasn't been
answering the garbage can before so
don't worry about it and she goes well
what if there is I was like if there is
I'll wake up tomorrow before you do and
I'll handle it so you don't see it and
then she says and then she goes okay
then that's fine and then we're chilling
and I'm bout to get back into sleep and
she goes nope I can't do it that's what
I was like okay I found the compromise
she agreed to it and then she went back
on it and that's why I got upset because
that was already like a 30 minute
conversation right before we're going to
sleep which I didn't think was necessary
because I already told her what I was
going to do I said that I was going to
clean it up or close the lid and make
sure there's no ants and before you wake
up I was gonna go downstairs and make
sure you don't see it are we going to
keep bickering
but doom this podcast is brought to you
by Fiverr where do you go to find
on-demand talent how much will it cost
how can you be certain they'll deliver
find the right freelancer can be
time-consuming frustrating and expensive
I said find finding fivers platform
helps keep businesses moving with a
network of trusted freelance talent my
friends yes I love Fiverr I use them for
just about everything if I want some
straight for freelance work with
deadlines straightforward pricing and
great communication I go with them a lot
of the times I'm literally on a time
crunch like I need to get something done
that day or maybe in a couple of days
and I don't have the typical people that
do work for me
available then I go on Fiverr just to
find it so Fiverr is easy you can find
what you're looking for instantly you
can search by service deadline price
reviews and a whole bunch more you'll
know exactly what you're paying for
upfront no negotiating needed 24/7
customer service check out vipre calm
today and receive 10% off your first
order by using my code g/b it's easy
find all the digital services you need
into one place at five-30 B again that's
fiverr.com code GB this is what it's
like being in a relationship but this is
just a clear example of the things that
you have to deal with when you start
living with somebody else and people
have different sets of rules with each
other so what bothers her normally as
her eyes to it what bothers what bothers
her doesn't really bother me and what
bothers me doesn't really bother her
yeah we had this weird thing you have
we're OCD oh my dear
let's not even get into who has more
weird OCD than you or me saying I was
just adding facts to what your ego
affects so I had this weird thing where
I like to keep things within a square
right just put in a box so there could
be random objects anywhere but I don't
like it scattered about so for example
if there's like keys coins or whatever
you can't just leave it on the tape
if there's a tray for it just put it in
the tray if there's chapsticks put it in
the tray see he's all about the witch I
compromise because as you know on your
table on your desk
I put square stuff so you could put your
accessories in there so it helps you
with your OCD for him he doesn't it
doesn't matter what's in there whether
there's trash that's been there for
months
have I ever locate I want you to
relocate if you're making me sound like
I'm a troll under grace when have I ever
looked trashed for months I don't want
anything remember before you left for
your vacate know your work Vicki no was
it your traveling my dear that was paper
and garbage in a trash can it was in a
trash can there was additional stuff but
I do really don't want to get into it
then we're gonna go back to the whole
bickering stuff and that is the end of
our bickering your this conversation is
making me look like the Miss Nagre and
you like the dirty fiancee which dirty
bastard boy you can say bastard
yes you were okay stay single guys how
about that just single people because at
this point people don't know this part
about the relationship stuff I think
when we when people have a conversation
about relationships they go you get to
have a partner who's always gonna be
there next to you for the rest of your
life well guess what
that's why I opened up an office to get
the hell away from her just kidding but
yeah but there's a lot of stuff that you
have to work through in order to it's
like it's like with my parents right I
used to wonder how my parents did it
because they they live I think a lot of
immigrant Asian parents when they open
up a business together with their
significant other and you know sometimes
with the small businesses they don't
really hire out a lot of people so it's
just that person your mom and your dad
next to each other for their whole life
my parents have spent every waking
moment together since I was born
they haven't been separated there's
never been a single day where they were
away from each other more than like a
few hours yeah the only time that
happened was when my mom's mom died in
Korea is she had to go over there or
that when my dad had to go help some
other sibling this is what I mean
tornado passes by rice cooker has flown
over whose head your dad's head what are
we talking about right now
remember you were told they didn't fly
past my head my mom threw that at my dad
but it's not because they didn't love
each other it was more along the lines
of they just spent too much time
together right so as much as you could
see a lot of positive things about the
person when you're with them too well
you know majority of the time those
small things tend to add up more than
the positive because they stick out a
lot more so my parents never gonna break
from each other so every time my dad
would complain or he would nag about
something or my mom would nag and
complain it wouldn't be like you would
hear that dag and then you'd be away for
a second yeah there's no break to like
get rid of that then they get a thoughts
or you know that moment exactly and
they're even beyond that to they'd ever
had a vacation the first vacation they
had was like I would say about six years
ago and that's when they went to Hawaii
together because my mom long story short
my mom used to work at a factory for
these very very wealthy people in Korea
well that person who owns that company
in Korea who was very very wealthy
became my mom's best became my mom's
best friend my mom used to worked at the
factory at first they for some reason
got along really well together because
yeah I called her honey she I found out
she was not actually my hand money but
she was his grandmother she has a very
very crass crass personality she's super
ghetto but her her husband happens to be
very rich because he kind of grew up
together so she just kind of kept all
that hood ghetto like country tendencies
my mom is like her very very similar to
her so they became really close friends
I guess as her from that point she I
think she became like a housemaid my mom
became a housemaid for her and then my
mom did like certain things that other
people wouldn't do like for example my
mom told me the story there was somebody
who was supposed to do yard work at
their whatever their mansion or their
house right and my mom is is working at
the house mm-hmm
all the other workers that were in the
house they watch this guy do work and he
wouldn't like takes cigarette breaks
smoke and he was taking forever to do it
basically what he was doing he was space
is stealing money because he's choosing
to work a lot slower so he could get
paid on the hour yeah so my mom comes
out and she goes you know I just she
show me what you're doing mm-hmm he goes
what are you supposed to do today he's
like I'm supposed to go okay I want to
see you do it and so he does it and she
goes cool
give me your tool and she starts doing
it right and she goes if I did this in
five minutes why do I see you sitting
here taking a smoke break having like
three different lunches she goes you
need to start doing work I was like if I
can do this you should be able to get
done than with this by today if you
don't get it done by today we're gonna
have a problem my mom's just like starts
reaming this guy and he starts cleaning
and then that apparently some of the
other workers told my head Moni what she
did and then she was like you know Wow
okay what I would be shocked because
back then mail would be like if I were a
man and be like exactly my mom's who are
you to tell me woman exactly my mom's
crazy dude so my mom got into this dude
space so sweet I'm glad and so I think
from that was like one of those reasons
why she got along so well with that lady
and then a you know a fat lo and behold
II became really really close friends
but that's like the type of person that
my mom was she's like in-your-face like
get [ __ ] done type of lady that's why
she never let go of your dad
I know but could you imagine that
personality living with my dad maybe
your dad's more calm he is calm to a
certain extent I'm definitely more like
my mom than I am my dad yeah see it I
think there was like a good balance you
need to have a good balance from each
other but when they're both fire it is
very hard and I feel like your fire and
I'm fire you are fired in and I think
more for you because I've it's weird how
you deal with other people versus how
you deal with people who are really
close to you mm-hmm
I think everything stings a little more
when somebody is really close to your
heart mm-hm so if I do something that
somebody else would have done that's
just like a decent friends like a good
friend is with your friends kind of like
whatever like sometimes when you have
interactions with specific people in
your life and see how they talk to you
or they treat you you're just kind of
like they're just having a bad day
whatever and then I'm just like yo
somebody said that she's left the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of them or if I said
that to you it would be game over yeah
cuz you know the amount of energy I have
to use to resolve that it's not worth it
it's all it's only used for certain
people because it needs to be resolved
for those people those friends after
that time passes by it's not gonna be a
big deal like we're not gonna talk about
it I think that's very smart because
when she told me about this one time as
she she basically went on like a
friend's triplets with the feel
refractor basically what did you just
say
a friendship no no right before that I
think it was my first time hearing that
I think that's very smart
what did I say thank you I wanted to
rephrase that
I always compliment you thank you okay
moving on mm-hmm anyways so she went on
this uh this friend's trip and she was
kind of venting to me about a small
little situation that happened between
her and one of her friends right and and
basically the girl kind of like popped
off on her for some random [ __ ] right
and I thought it was very disrespectful
for what for what the situation called
for she didn't have to speak to her that
way
and so for for Muriel did she just kind
of let it go apologize and was like okay
well if you feel that way I'm sorry
bubble a blah explain her situation
however for me if I if I was in your
situation I probably would have taken
that person's side and what a [ __ ]
curse the mountain below you don't
[ __ ] disrespect me like that in front
of people slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
you that's what I would say yeah but the
reason why I thought what she did was
really smart is because number one these
are friends that she doesn't see often
mm-hmm
they see each other intermittently it
was fun for a majority of the trip and
so for her it was like why should I have
to correct this behavior out of this
person of a friends and I rarely see
anyways it doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah
like just they've always been like this
they like to argue they like to debate
all the time so let them be them
and I'll just let this one go because
I'm not gonna see her for another six
months anyway so doesn't yeah and it's
another thing it's like it's a group
trip and I didn't want to bring it was
our last day yeah
and I don't want to ruin that trip just
because I need to correct someone you
know it's like that's I think that's
where my consideration comes in it's
like it's not my trip it's our trip and
I want to make sure like and the other
friends they'd have been like it didn't
they didn't even notice it I asked him
later oh and I didn't ask but like we
brought them kind of had that
conversation and they're like I had no
idea and they just enjoy the trip the
whole time I don't know how you so I'm I
don't know why I'm just gonna swallow it
and just let it go because a month from
now on no one's gonna even care I'm not
gonna care I think for me it's hard
because I think that's a smarter move to
do just for my personality sense yeah
but if I had to deal with that with you
it's as well because you will see each
other everyday so it's a different
situation yeah I think for me even if
it's somebody I don't see for a long
time and this is probably a huge flaw of
mine is because I know that in the
future I'm gonna see them again and if
they do it again mm-hmm and it's been
six months and I don't address it at
that point I feel weird addressing
something that happened six months ago
because I should have addressed it then
when it happened but I feel like for you
it's fine because if it happens again
you're okay just letting it go because
you're not gonna see them again also I
could prevent myself have that happening
again it's just you know it's not
something that it's not a habit that
they do it's just a situation and the
reaction that came around so it's not
it's not a repetitive thing I would say
and it's it's not worth it
sometimes it's just for me it's always
worth it though like I had that I have
to like take somebody aside and talk to
miss like which is why I saw a lot of
things and try to go around your way my
dear but you do too you can't always be
the right person you know I mean well
it's not about being right but you're
doing it because it's in your like you
gotta let it out for yourself you're
like this is not right so I need to fix
it for my my selfish reason maybe yeah I
think I think beyond that though it's
because what is selfish because it's
something that I'm gonna have to deal
with again like if that happens again I
won't be able to control myself as well
as if I just dealt with it right now I'm
exaggerating when I say I would take
them aside and be like hey you know [ __ ]
you
I would just tell them like hey yo do
you think that was appropriate for you
to talk to me like that sure like it and
another thing what's going on like why
did you do that if it was one-on-one I
think maybe I would have brought it up
but because it was a situation was a
group of people and another thing is
women are different this podcast is
brought to you by keeps did you know two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 the best way to prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have hair left I wish I
gave this advice to my buddy Dan in high
school because he banked on his luscious
hair he thought he would have kept his
luscious locks forever well Dan Dan
prevention was key and keeps could have
helped Jim great thing about keeps is
that they offer generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there you can also get treated from
home by getting your medications
delivered to you every three months save
yourself your child self anyways from
having to go to the pharmacy to grab
that hair loss medication yeah you don't
need to deal with that so listen if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps calm / brain to
receive your first month of treatment
for free
that's ke PS calm / brain once again
that's ke EPS calm / brain keeps baby I
think men when they do that from men to
men it's like okay it's very
straightforward there's no other meaning
to it
but for a woman there's a lot of stuff
going on when you say something like
that we're like we're just attached to a
lot of different emotions and thoughts
so it doesn't come off the same way and
I think that's the benefit of men it's
just like very straightforward okay
a a 2a but for us eight it does not is
never a 2a it's like a two options from
A to Z isn't that exhausting though how
it is that's just how our brain work I
do see that a lot though especially with
a lot of my personal girlfriends right
even from back home I told the story
before on the podcast so back in the day
there was this group they were called
the innocent a the innocent a
so baby kind of named themselves the
innocent eight that was like their
seventh grade - all the way through high
school you know what we like screenings
like screen names
I was the Asian little girl zero one two
home anyway so that was their little
thing right but even watching how that
group fell apart it was all a
communication issue right so I think
that what I see a lot from a lot of
female friends and I'm not saying this
is a generality or a general truth for
all women but just from my whatever 32
years of living that I've seen from all
the girls around me I feel like
sometimes the girls have this thing of
you guys I want to say live very well
but it's more like you guys can put up a
front of like okay hahaha and but then
what happens is when that happens you
still feel angry and upset uh-huh and it
seeps out in other ways so whether you
go behind their back and you're talking
about it with another friend within the
group yeah
and then that gossip starts to happen
and then that person starts to change
the mind of another girl in that you
about that person and it starts to bleed
out and then you don't even know where
the hate started at that point so and
but then when you guys all meet together
it's like oh hey how are you oh my god
girl you're here
and then everything's cool but then when
you walk away then it goes back to that
original hate or whatever that issue was
and it goes back to talking [ __ ] again
it goes oh did you see the way she was
talking me today it's like yeah it's
just like that last time it's so high
school
oh but I see that happen a lot within
girl groups and I don't know what that
is like why we mmm hold on ooh
cuz you know what I'm talking about
right it does it's funny because I mean
I can't say I am not one of those girls
cuz I'm sure I am but I try to put
myself yea minimize it because cuz I
understand Eli I said I I think I'll do
that I used to do that a lot and
sometimes too if I if I don't really
care about the person I don't know I'm
different I usually what I say in front
of your faces I use a signal yeah you're
you're different
yeah but us girls I don't know I think
we do bond over gossiping that is a true
fact you know there's no way that that's
not true cause I get it gossiping is fun
it is fun but I think like I said like
our brains or you know like when guys
meet up we you guys don't complement
each other this close or alike you know
bring something up that's like very
irrelevant and like start talking about
that I'd be like oh my god that shirt is
so cute where'd you get it was from this
like I got it for 50% off yeah I think
we do it when you guys when there's like
big purchases or some shoes you got a
new car about you oh [ __ ] yeah only a
big purchase but we do a lot of small
talks and not that that's bad or
anything like you know it's it's a good
conversation it's like you know like in
Japan we talk about whether or like all
today is a grandmother
it sure is it's a great weather that's
all they always start start the
conversation but I think we just have
this like I said we are brain and we
have so many emotions attached to in so
we take things in a different message
you know if you say oh dude that phone
is dope you say do to a girl they might
take it like what the Freak like do you
think sometimes girls they're a little
hyper analytical about small things we
are we are emotion because our emotions
are very attached to it I think that's
what it is like our emotions tell us
what we should think and from there our
brain is just like thinking of so many
different things it's like trying to
recapture what happened in the past or
like with someone else it said this you
know like Tara's house that one girl
what's her name the rest alert girl oh
yeah yeah yeah she's getting advises
from people who heard things and
thinking that that it would work yeah
it's just it doesn't make sense what the
hell like why would you why would you do
that but like there's so much emotions I
are attached to it that like she thinks
like she's in a drama she's like the
main character and that's gonna work out
like we do that a lot we where I was
like it's exhausting it is it's so
exhausting why do you think we have so
many wrinkles just relax man like it's
not that big of a deal but there's
certain guys honestly yeah of course I'm
not saying all girls are like this and
I'm gonna cut those guys out real fast
though
I think genetically there has to be some
kind of survival situation yeah we're
just about what that reason is but
there's definitely a specific that is
why male are attracted to us which
they're so opposite from them maybe
maybe you think we're very like
like we got so many layers didn't talk
about on Terrace house who one of my
favorite people on there that's so dumb
both know the guy that uh he actually
left he was the one that cooked the
pasta and egg and the broccoli in the
water together
well spider-man spider-man boy it was so
sweet when he left it was it was he left
us the broccoli boy as broccoli boy you
know there was a recent picture that I
saw of him he's modeling now like um
cute Amica no no Amica is that any come
no I don't know I don't know yeah but
he's been model he looks like me know
from Xinhua he looks he looks like him
when he first came out yeah he looks
like that yeah he does if you guys go
back look up a picture of this guy named
e me new from Xinhua she is like one of
the og kpop girls that came out with
this other group called h.o.t they were
like the two tops I had a huge crush on
him he was Korean moon I that Japanese
kid looks just like him when I kept
looking at him I was like who does he
look like yeah when he smiles he looks
just like it and she was like kpop heron
Oh what are you bringing back
he's a very the reason why I liked him I
know a lot of people got frustrated with
him because of I think they took his
stupidity as laziness
he's very inexperienced he's a pampered
kid yeah taken care of right and
everything was kind of just laid out for
him
and so with him on that show I think a
lot of people felt a lot of negative
feelings and a lot of disdain towards
him because they kind of confused his
inability to be an adult with laziness
he wasn't lazy if you look at throughout
that show he consistently yeah trying to
be he was just on a slower end it just
doesn't know how yeah exactly like
compare him to that 19 euros chef boy oh
that's different that's like - yeah
exactly if you compare those two they're
both kind of slow but one is actually
trying a slower pace where at the other
one is totally take advantage of his
family exactly so he doesn't have like
he's such a innocent good soul it's just
you know as an adult it's hard to you
don't have that patience as you did when
you were younger right yeah because
you're just kind of living life and
doing whatever but when you're in a
group setting with an adult
respect this guy to be an adult and he's
not doing it people get frustrated a
little bit but that's why he had a lot
of good older men around him that were
very patient with him yeah I was man I
just be like Dawg get your [ __ ] together
I think you would have actually adored
him probably I would have taken him
under my wing yeah this is what you do
yeah yeah cook business in that oh yeah
totally you would you would have done
the other way I like that though I like
I think the quality that I like about
people the most and I don't think it
gets appreciated a lot is when somebody
tries I think effort is the biggest
thing I think that's the reason why I
like you so much is because even though
we fought a lot so much in the beginning
like we used to fight all the time
I think every time we fought we always
leveled up so it was when we figured out
what the solution was even though it
wasn't perfect we always tried right so
it was hey I don't want you to do this
anymore it was cool I never said I would
never do it I would always say that I
would try because I kind of learned
early on that when you kind of give
somebody that you're with that you care
about false promises Nathan get their
heart broken mm-hmm so if for example if
you told me hey I don't want you to I
don't know clip your toenails in the
bathroom sink anymore right have you
said that right and I would say okay
I'll remember not I'll try to remember
not to I'll try my best you know you do
do that you say you will try which I
like hearing that rather than okay I
will do it because try means that
there's an effort that you're gonna add
to it
when you say you're just gonna do it
it's just it does sound like it could
sound like a false hope because like mmm
if you could just do it why couldn't you
do it it's a lot of pressure and also to
it kind of you're also expecting
perfection out of yourself yeah which is
not gonna happen like we all attempt
stuff yeah and habits are hard to break
so if I say that I'm gonna do something
I say I try first versus something like
something terrible
you know let's say I don't notice I
cheated on you or something if you like
I'm gonna try not to I know what's
eating he say he'll try so maybe not
this round maybe not this year me this
time
I'll really try not and if I do it again
listen I tried face it was really hard
she was already butt naked in my bed
that those are different situations
right my if I if it's I don't know
something like that like clipping your
toenails in them you know that's why it
that's what I'm saying that girls are
just you know you asked me to calm down
time to time but girls are just
genetically different you got to know
that we just have a lot of ups and downs
not to mention Tom Riddle comes around
every month now I could say that because
I finally watch Mary but just an example
she get into that later just an example
of how her emotions are so erratic this
morning she woke up as the happiest
person on earth she and I had two very
different dreams going to imitate how
she was this morning she goes I had a
really good dream today and I'm like Oh
last night I'm like Oh what was your
dream I had a dream and me and gal gadot
were best friends up to okay I gave you
some good news for you on the other hand
you're like oh yeah I had a dream and I
don't even remember 90% of it all I
remember is that oh yeah and I stepped
on something and it was brown and I
thought was poop or he said the other
word and I go to the bathroom and I was
actually me so and I was like why what
oh yeah
and it turns out okay well first of all
it's like that's that's nice you had a
poop dream but it wasn't poop it was me
so it was me so so the dream was really
weird it was like running away from
someone I was playing football with a
few friends you play football in real
life we used to play like catch football
flag football yeah we should play we
play a street football too when in
middle school high school middle school
okay cuz I did too
yeah I'm like do you usually play for
fun every well it's hard to play
football as an adult now you have to get
a fat group of people I don't know right
so we split football so we're we're
tossing the ball around in this field in
this dream and then well as we're
tossing it back and forth this is all
highschool friends but were adults
I had these I had these uh white and
suede gray Jordan ones on and they look
really [ __ ] dope and so we're tossing
this ball around and then I stepped into
mud and I look and look at it and it
looks like [ __ ] and so I remember I take
off the shoe I'm going towards the
bathroom and this is like this it's like
a weird field and it's like a high
school but it's not mm-hmm high school /
college campus with the field in the
middle and then I go off into this room
and to go wash it off right and so let's
sleep well I don't know but I walk into
this room and it looks like a dormitory
right a dormitory sink so you've had to
show those shared bathrooms and doors
right so I walk in there and I'm washing
it off and I look at it and I'm like oh
this isn't did you make it it's me so
and so I went to smell it oh it's just
it's just a white miso and so I started
washing it off and it's scrubbing it and
then I get some soap from the dispenser
and as I said to scrub and wash it off
when I look up it been the the bathroom
sink it's just a sink and it's in my
dormitory room and I'm not in the
dormitory bathroom anymore
so it transformed when I look up into my
actual dorm bedroom and so as I'm
washing the shoe I look it up I'm like
oh okay cool okay well if I'm watching
these shoes I might as well just go wash
my other shoes so I go towards my other
shoe collection which is on the other
side of the wall and I grab some other
shoes to clean and that I notice in this
room my my dorm bed is pressed up
against the wall and as the headboard
the headboard is just stacks of shoes
and I'm like oh why did I put it there I
should be organizing these shoes going
back and then when I look back to the
other side of the wall there's more
shoes lined up and on top of that shelf
of shoes there's this Elsa doll uh-huh
I'm from frozen I'm like the [ __ ] why do
I have an Elsa doll here and by the way
this room is very dimly lit and there's
only sunlight coming through through
some shades and when I grabbed the Elsa
doll the Elsa doll turns into an actual
Elsa doll when I pick it up I turn it
around and the Elsa doll becomes really
long it's a long doll with like the long
limbs with no fingers or anything like
that and the face is blank oh look
creepy I'm thinking why do I have this
doll and so I'm like okay cool and then
right where the shoes are there's a Fuji
film xt2 aps-c camera and I'm like oh I
didn't know I had this camera so I went
to go grab the
and then I was like oh yeah I was
looking for a small camera to have so I
could just carry around in the travel
photography I'm gonna place the doll
back I look back there's two of them and
they're sitting next to each other
looking at me
how creepy they don't have a face and so
I'm getting a little creeped out right
so I take the dolls and I flip them down
and I put them face down I would go I
went to go back to the shelf and I grab
a bag and the bag is from Harry Potter
world like you know like one of those
like gifts today yeah yeah yeah so I
went to go grab the bat I went to go
grab the two the two dolls uh-huh and I
stuffed them in the bag
and then I woke up but it was like it
was weird that was what that's what I
dreamt about it was his doll that kept
on changing his faces constantly he was
like creeping me out yeah that's kind of
scary
I was gonna say your dream sounds like
your personality like a TD oh how dare
you cuz like it's like you you're
cleaning your shoe and you thought it
was proven and goes to me so you're like
oh it's me so and you look up and it's
like oh it's not my bathroom anymore
it's actually the dorm rooms like oh I
might as well just clean the shoes and
you look at the shoes and you're like oh
why are the shoes there and then you
look over there and you're like oh
there's Elsa and it's just so basically
you'd end up with cleaning your shoes
would you can you be sure that there was
a demon doll staring at you that's so
funny cuz you're cleaning in your dream
that's right it's how I do it baby and I
asked him in the morning I was like they
just sleep I was like yeah I slept
really well crazy talk man your viewer I
feel like you work a lot in your dreams
no I'm just like I just make out good I
was happy my dreams are very odd though
oh yeah when I had these weird dreams
the thing is I wish I could loose a
dream where I can control what's going
on that'll be really fun to animate your
like makeup oh you would you have no
idea if I could tell you some of the
dreams that I've had I they're so vivid
it's unreal and I remember a lot of
these things because I write them down
did I tell you about the dream that I
had about a friend that turned into a
fox No okay so this dream is super vivid
and it's kind of a representation of
what I feel about this person too but so
in this dream I'm walking in this force
right so a lot of tall trees and light
is kind of leaking through the trees as
I'm walking through the forest
going through the brushes I'm going
through all these thick trees and these
and through the thickets I look forward
and I see this really large large
mansion right the mansion the the walls
are are kind of like stucco but it looks
like a very old-fashioned kind of like
Danish Dutch house but is a huge mansion
at the top has red brick red red tiles
for the roofs and so as I walk into the
house there's like this huge stairway
that goes up mm-hmm
right all dark wood everything else but
it doesn't look really creepy because
it's it's kind of like that golden hour
sunlight that's good you all the window
so it looks very nice and pleasant when
I go up this winding staircase I go into
this room and when I walk into the room
it's a daycare and the daycare you see a
bunch of colored blocks a lot of toys
like the colors that I remember from the
daycare was a green blue red yellow just
very bright a lot of bright clothes that
you would see when I walk in I noticed
that there's this huge robot this robot
is standing and it turns around this
gigantic robot very square turns around
I look at him he goes he comes up to me
and he goes be careful who you trust and
I'm like what do you mean and he goes
you need to be careful with who you
trust and then when he says that he
starts to malfunction and he starts
breaking down he's freaking out and so
I'm assuming that this robbed this robot
is going to attack me all right and I
might have told this on the podcast but
not this this specifics but as that
robot starts breaking down and you know
freaking out it falls over and you see
it's like the eyes kind of blinking
starts to go out and then when I turn
around there's this Fox it's Fox like a
standing up Fox like a human Fox in
human clothes grabs my hand and says hey
we have to go and so the Fox grabs me
right and we go down the stairs we get
into this like there's a large fan or
SUV I can't remember I think it wasn't
bad we get into the van and you know the
Fox is like clearly worried and he goes
it's good I got you in time and I'm
looking at this Fox and it says I you
know be careful who you trust and I'm
thinking about this fox huh alright and
this Fox and I look at the Fox I'm like
oh this isn't a fox this is my friend I
know this person right and somebody I
know in real life and so as this Fox is
talking I'm like hey I need you to pull
over like pull over the car you know and
so as the as the Fox is starting to pull
over you like what's wrong I'm like
there's something a little off about the
situation this is really we
and by the way Oh actually what happened
was it wasn't that the the so the Fox
this is what the Fox grabbed me right
and the Fox turned into the friend and
then back into the Fox so it went from
Fox
uh-huh that grabbed me out the building
and then with a person who was driving
was the person that are you watching or
were you seeing it from your perspective
I was looking from my perspective and
that Fox turned into the person that I
knew and then it turned back into the
Fox okay so that's how I knew that that
was the Fox I I wrote it down somewhere
in my notes and as we're driving were
like running away from something like in
a very weird situation and because I
remember what that robot said is it
don't trust you know careful who you
trust
well I told him to pull me over and so I
was like okay so what do you want to do
and I literally kick this person out the
car because over the warning the robot
gave me huh huh but then and then as I
kick the person out the car which is the
Fox person they starts to growl gets
really [ __ ] angry you know like just
really vicious and I start driving the
car off and then the freeway that we're
on eventually turns into a neighborhood
and then I dump off the van to another
Fox family and tell them to get rid of
it I wake up oh so you betrayed your
friend I'm sure my friend though because
the robot told me to be careful who I
trust well how do you trust the robot
you know know the road I don't know oh
the robot actually I don't want to say
names but the robot was had the voice of
the person that managed the person that
was in that car so this person that I
didn't trust who was a friend of mine
was an artist is an artist and that
person that had the robot was the voice
of that person's manager at the time
they're not they're not actually working
together anymore oh because of some
trust issues isn't that crazy
oh wait was that before after that dream
though this was uh they were still
working together before the dream hmm
and then they split is it sometimes I
feel like the dream some I don't really
think about it but then when something
happens like this I want my dream was
about
my mom's you have any idea how many
times my mom calls me per week cuz she
has a dream that I died or got into a
car accident
dreams are opposites and then nothing
has ever happened yeah she called me the
other day and I was in the shower so I
didn't pick
the phones my brother call me he goes
hey mom had a bad dream about you again
I was like okay you know she's been
trying to call you and she just want me
to call you see if you're okay that
makes sense because you have the worst
karma but you never die I'm fine though
yeah she had a dream my mom had a dream
that you and I you murdered somebody
oh yeah I'm had a dream that you
murdered somebody that's Frankie and
then we buried that person that we came
by a lot of money because we killed that
person or you did that's right and then
we were living in this mansion and I was
telling my mom that she can't tell me
about that she has to keep a secret oh
my god that's the show we just watched
had this happened before I watch the
show though oh wow
and so my mom was telling me that that
was that's what her dream was and that I
had to live with this secret and so I
was she was really concerned about me
she's like she was like in the dream I
was like what's gonna happen if your
YouTube fans find out that you if you're
a part of a murder that's what you're
worried about it you know that's
probably the last thing she has to worry
about with a in our family I know yeah
dreams Wow well anyways guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast I'm gonna fix this flickering
screen Bing though the place looks
amazing yeah this is just as this is
just an easy foundation or just the
start but we're gonna work on some of
the connectivity issues that we're
having with this TV but other than that
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast you can find Mariel at
Mariel underscore underscore song on
Instagram and yeah everybody this
podcast is here just to keep you company
on your everyday we talked about the
green and bickering big grain and then
relationship stuff moving in together
and having to deal with each other yeah
we're dreams any good stuff there's a
lot of good stuff I said that you're
smart you look so pretty today oh thank
you and you're the best oh you're the
best
oh I mean yes yes you're the best too
you're never coming down as pod casting
it anyways guys we'll see you guys next
time catch us on Spotify and everything
else and uh yeah baby I love you very
much